the crypto Community celebrated a big
win this week with the US court of
appeals ruling in favor of firm
grayscale but late yesterday the SEC
delayed a decision on a round of Bitcoin
ETF applications joining us now Anthony
Pompano founder and partner of pomp
Investments Anthony great to have you
here on set but great to have you back
in New York um what did you make of this
whole thing I I don't think anyone was
really surprised with the delays
yesterday the six delays um gives them
another 45 dayses kind of figure it out
one of the important things about the
sec's loss in that lawsuit was the judge
didn't say hey you to approve the ETF
they just said that you have to go back
and figure out are you going to approve
or deny on other uh kind of causes and
so look we have future space ETFs I
think we will get a spot Bitcoin ETF the
question is when one of the things that
people aren't talking about though is
this ETF is going to be a demand shock
right there is going to be assets that
flow into this industry when that occurs
but it closer and closer we get to the
having it will coincide with a supply
shock in that having and I think that we
could see a repeat of 2020 where we go
up quite uh significantly in price if
that occurs wow um let's sort of backup
in terms of the price action in response
to the overturning of the decision we
saw all of those gains wiped out and you
said that it's sort of not a surprise so
I mean why did we see those gains in the
first place and and what is the so the
play right now is to be long is what
you're saying I I I think that um you
know bitcoin's really interesting it was
up like 80% to start the year it's now
down to about 60% up uh since the start
of the year in July and August it was
down September's historically been a
pretty bad month for Bitcoin um so you
get some of those like seasonality type
stuff that are playing in here as well
but uh people who pay attention every
single day to the crypto industry
they're not surprised I think what's
happening though is uh you've had a uh
kind of a a turning of the holder base
right you used to have all crypto native
people who held Bitcoin now you're
starting to get more Wall Street people
kind of retail investors and so those
people who don't pay attention 24/7 365
they're probably a little surprised but
the Crypton native folks that they kind
of expected this what do you think about
the way that gendler the head of the SEC
has navigated this whole thing yeah I
think he's got an impossible job right
um if you think about what The
Regulators have to do is they basically
want to encourage Innovation you know I
call it like embracing the
entrepreneurial DNA of the United States
we want to be a leader uh both in
capital markets and in technology at the
same time they want to protect investors
and so um I think that what they've been
very clear about is their perspective
which is Bitcoin is the asset that is
kind of passed through that regulatory
threshold it is not a security it's a
commodity uh and they're kind of
treating it that way uh the rest of the
assets they obviously think are
securities and so there's obviously some
litigation that's going on uh there's a
lot of debate and I think disagreement
between the crypto community and
Regulators um but the beauty of America
is that people will go to court they're
going to lay out their arguments and the
courts will decide sometimes The
Regulators will be right other times
Regulators won't be right but that's why
we have those court systems and the
judicial system and makes America the
greatest country in the world you you
sound admittedly Ian I'm kind of
surprised you sound a little more
sympathetic towards Mr gendler as maybe
I would have expected because many who
share your passion and advocacy for
Bitcoin have been much more harsh toward
towards him at the end of the day we can
yell and scream we can argue you know
name call do all the things that people
do but we still have to work together
right at the end of the day The
Regulators are always going to be the
regulators and so my thought process is
if we spend our time more focused on
educating and and kind of trying to
bridge that Gap uh uh get them to
understand why this technology is
important how it's already helped quite
a bit of people um that's probably a
more productive use of energy and time
than it would be to sit and just yell
and scream at each other uh cuz at the
end of the day the yelling and the
screaming just gets people to dig their
heels in and then people don't want to
work together right but my belief is
that a Bitcoin ETF will be approved in
the United States of America it will
lead to billions and billions of dollars
of inflows uh at the same time I think
that uh Regulators are having to get up
to speed they're getting educated and
the more that they learn the more they
realize the technology is not going away
I mean stable coins is like the a story
that uh I think Regulators are kind of
scratching their head around we've seen1
trillion doar of transaction volume
settled with stable coins that's the
same transaction volume as Visa right so
when you start to think about this like
wait a minute nobody uses that stuff
except for the Dollar on blockchain is
used just as much as Visa is used that
is a mind-blowing statistic where
regulators technologists and frankly
politicians all have to get together and
decide how are we going to use this
technology because if we don't do it
here in the United States people
internationally are going to continue to
use this and we're seeing International
U usage and Adoption of these
Technologies explode does America want
to be a leader or do we want to be a
follower historically we've been a
leader so let's go lead let's go back
and assume that a Bitcoin ETF is
approved um how do you think about the
trades we saw initially coinbase go up
but you sort of wondered do you need
something like a coinbase if you can buy
an ETF on any exchange on your Schwab
account for instance um so how do you
start how do you think about it so you
know we're an investor in coinbase have
been for a long time and and I think
that if you're a retail investor and you
wanted exposure to bitcoin over the last
two three five years you probably went
and figured out a way to do it right and
so I don't think that there's a ton of
inflows that are going to be happening
from uh retail inv investors I do think
though that Sovereign wealth funds or
very large institutions they're not
going on coinbase and buying you know
spot Bitcoin right and so I think that
that's where the ETF inflows could
happen I think coinbase has done a
fantastic job they've onboarded more
people to bitcoin than any other company
in the country or in the world uh and if
you look at by being a public company
what they've really done is they've held
the flag and said look we want to be a
regulated institution we want to be a
big brand I think they're doing a
fantastic job you talked about a moment
I want to just get back real quick to
use case stuff um talked about stable
coins and you talked about these
astounding statistics that that you
pointed out what about for Bitcoin do do
you think we're closer now any closer
now than we were say two years ago about
real use case for Bitcoin because I feel
like that's still suspect yeah I I think
it's a very fair question right and the
first part of that you have to Define
what is the use case and so some people
will say hey it's a store of value we're
going to buy it we're going to hold it
we're never going to sell it and it's
going to be this amazing way to protect
our purchasing power other people want
it to be the El El ronic cash that was
kind of mentioned in the white paper and
we're going to all you know drop dollars
and and go spend Bitcoin I tend to think
that there's a sequence to it maybe it
becomes that electronic cash maybe it
doesn't I'm not sure but I know today
for sure it's being used as that store
of value it's you know half a trillion
dollar asset there's tens of millions of
people if not hundreds of millions of
people around the world they buy it they
hold it and they simply just want to
protect their purchasing power right you
could think of it as like a digital gold
and from that standpoint holding is a
use case right now if you then start to
evolve the definition of use case and
say hey I need it to be that electronic
cash sure it has really high transaction
volumes and and has all these different
uh applications that people are trying
to build but I don't think anyone with a
straight face would say hey Bitcoin is
replacing the US dollar today for the
majority I mean people have done that
though plenty of people have have
actually tried to make that case have
you mellowed somewhat on bitcoin no I
I'm still incredbly bullish on this who
are you and what' you do with Anthony
Pomano no it's just understanding I
think that when when you look at crypto
assets in general right um the market
data is changing and so one of the the
things that I find Most Fascinating is
people in the industry seem to be buying
Bitcoin and holding it and they're using
that to protect the purchasing power and
then if they want if you're an Argentina
I talked to an Argentinian uh
entrepreneur recently and he said to me
everyone in Argentina wants to get out
of the pay right obviously it's 100%
inflation it's this horrible situation
but they're not going and buying Bitcoin
immediately what they're doing is they
actually want stable coins right and the
reason why they want stable coins is
because they want to get paid in dollars
from their companies they want to pay
other people Etc and so if you buy
Bitcoin and you're using that as your
store of value and then you're using a
stable coin to actually transact value
that seems again what the Market's
showing us that's what people are doing
good to see you nice see you guys as
well welcome back to New York